jean le fait vous venez de tourner aux
côtés de lino ventura lé dernier film de
georges lautner qui s'appelle ne nous
fâchons pas il semble que vous vous
tailler un peu la part du lion dans ce
film c'est votre premier grand groupe
est ce que c'est votre avis j'étais
content la mort au début à la lecture du
film parce que michel audiard j'ai eu la
chance que michel audiard et écrivent le
rôle spécialement pour moi évidemment
c'est un avantage surtout écrit par
michel audiard c'est un avantage pour un
comédien d'avoir un rôle écrit sur
mesure déjà au départ est ce que vous
êtes plutôt le personnage gay dans la
vie oui dans la vie oui quand quand j'ai
pas les ennuis comme tout le monde quand
on a des ennuis on peut pas éduquer mais
en général
moi j'aime bien j'aime bien rigoler
mais chalon c'est un personnage un peu
misérable
et est-ce que vous employez reçoit entre
autres pas mal de gif oui c'est
commencer que ce soit nécessaire pour
faire rire fois parce que franchement je
crois qu'on me vole bien quand vous
recevez pas mal de gif bah oui parce que
c'est un d'egypte sont en situation
alors évidemment quand je reçois une
paire de gifles données par lino ventura
qui est quand même
physiquement il est un petit peu plus
costauds quoi vous regardez
comme c'est en situation ces droits les
pieds en général on s'y attend pas
beaucoup
mais en fait il est donc bien une map en
fait trop mal passé que le comics est
uniquement un physique un physique et
puis puis la façon de jouer aussi mais
ça c'est instinctif ont fait ça
instinctivement où j'ai toujours aimé
faire l'imbécile pourtant même à l'école
j'étais envoyé de deux collèges à cause
de ça parce que j'aimais faire rire je
mets ça c est une satisfaction sans être
prétentieux d'antan les genres et ans
c'est vrai très à l'aise je devais être
pharmacien
et puis nous sommes emballés pas vous
pousser mes parents c'est ce que c'est
juste la province je suis du nord et
puis mes parents auraient voulu que je
sois pharmaciens mais moi mon idée
c'était toujours
faire le vin baissez vous nouveau
théâtre au cinéma ou dans la vie
et puis
je chante je chantais du mois
j'avais une voix de base évidemment une
bonne passe avec mon physique c'est
assez curieux et comme je voulais
m'évader de
ma famille ma femme ait été pour le
métier de comédien mais surtout chanteur
c'était sa pose et le personnage que
c'était
assez particulier les deux chanteurs
alors je dis bah moi je veux bien dans
le fond ça ne me déplaît pas du tout et
j'ai travaillé au conservatoire de lille
et valenciennes et je me suis présenté
aux conservateurs de paris comme
chanteur comme base chantant et j'ai eu
la chance d'être reçu au conservatoire
de paris
et vous savez qu'en général les
chanteurs d'opéra et l'opéra-comique
sont très mauvais comédien
néo conservateurs de paris avait décidé
de faire une classe de comédie pour les
chanteurs
et c'était rené ciment qui devait faire
les cours de comédie pour les chanteurs
et rené simon me voyant un jour chanter
m'a dit écoute je me vois c'est
incontestable mais avec ta gueule vous
faire autre chose vous jouer la comédie
parce que moi quand tout chante de
l'opéra l'opéra comique qui me fait rien
[Musique]